c'est vrai je ne me mets moi non
l'adaptation en radio théâtre de la
crise tu te souviendras deux mois a été
une belle occasion de réunir la
distribution originale
il ya comme un plaisir de retrouver les
gens avec qui on a dansé le 4 ou 5 1 ça
fait plaisir de retrouver le texte une
écoute c'est comme si les poumons se
rappelait ou respirer ça c'est curieux
immense succès au théâtre
la caisse a aussi été adapté au cinéma
jusque chez moi est-ce qu'on commence
bientôt tu te souviendras moi raconte
l'histoire d'une famille ébranlé par la
maladie d'alzheimer mais c'est aussi le
point de départ pour une réflexion plus
large
la pièce dépasse la mémoire personnelle
mais venant la mémoire collective pina
socialement qu'est-ce qu'on est aussi
par rapport à ce que notre rapport à la
mémoire à l'histoire justement d ok donc
tous les vieux ensemble quelque part et
pour le rapport avec des plus jeunes qui
pourront transmettre devoir répondre et
ça déjà forte
la pièce résonne avec encore plus
d'acuité dans le contexte actuel à cette
époque si à ce moment aussi avec tout ce
qu'on a entendu et vu de ce qui se passe
dans les ch et celle des disons que ça
résonne c'est vraiment comme un coup de
poing dans le front tu te souviendras
deux mois présente aussi une rencontre
intergénérationnelle
la version radio théâtre permettra de
découvrir l'oeuvre sous un nouveau jour
le public est interpellé il est condamné
à être un spectateur actif est condamné
a émis à imaginer la couleur de la veste
si on parle d'une veste lui va définir
sa couleur et sa sera pas sans repos
était prémâché par la production des a
cédé mousse et des répliques c est une
musique en fait je pense qu'on entend la
musique des répliques du dialogue tout
ça encore mieux que cau théâtre parce
que l'oeil c'est juste les mots
non soir ici guylaine tremblay radio
canada présentera cette radio théâtre au
cours des prochains mois après leur
diffusion à la radio ils seront
disponibles sur le site internet et sur
l'application radio canada audio du
sinai bay alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal